definitely has a Cassandra yeah I what
it's I it was it was definitely in the
in the beta stages but he was he was
messing with the character for sure okay
on the other sign you know how we talked
about three three characters for link
wars there's also three characters for
Lola mix right Yoshimitsu yep
a strong yep so I mean oh right and we
already saw them you know earlier
normally reasoning in play the Yoshi and
a stress but let's see what happens
he said double down on the Mina pic yeah
I remember
specifically since you're on the desk I
guess I can use this as an example on
rich Styx's stream he was practicing a
lot of that Astaroth i mean you know i
yeah i he had to have it ready for the
for the finals right you gotta have a
have every tool available to you for
whatever matchup you may need I'm not
entirely sure with low load designs is
the matchup that he wants to use that
particular thing in but uh he's quite
possibly the most seasoned player on the
on the bus the squad pretty much so it's
it's it's I have no doubt in my mind
that he has plans for for each tart so
that may or may not come out
thumbs up both smiling already it's
gonna be sick freed versus Yoshi
I love okay I'm so excited for this
match great I'm going to there there I
guess like their primary mains here this
is this is what they've been known for
for years and years and years right link
wars despite the fact that he was
playing a lot of alcohol and full
caliber fly if there was many events
where he was actually winning with choli
sick from that - he's up against the
wall so he's got to deal with the fix up
we saw through him up against the wall
earlier the LCQ is it god damn did he
make it look like it hurt and I oh my
goodness getting the cheap old pictures
the GI get away from me 3k oh wow what
an extension right there and despite the
fact of the second hint hint because he
was in the air the other two hits were
still able to connect after that he's
the first round going to lower me with
punished right they're getting this much
ham it is possible that so much oh I'm
trying to go for a low item selfie
unfortunately this is the extension
they're using though his own bar and now
health photos are a passive pretty funky
even right now it's up in front of them
tarqell I can see his active he hit him
out of three for a all right oh my god
those are the lows for Jade spins out of
control just a little bit deadly from
oak and it's not a lot of health left
but there comes the see that's not
punishable on block but he got caught
stepping backwards yeah forcing him to
gain a bar
right now link horse is having a lot of
trouble report easy definitely I'll
putting the damage though sorry he just
needs a couple of chances I feel like I
mean check the car gauge on low you're
right oh my god but there's a dark
latency to save him that was kind of
what he had to do there's a break attack
because he's in full charge b6 is
unfortunately not gonna give him a ton
right there but he does get the 3p all
the whip on the break attacker than the
low low low with the no round brown on
Lilly course behold my magnificence well
hit up with the feet though hit it with
the feet claps let's go low low bring
him out I think I think he's gonna wait
till you know he's for sure solidified
you know what no what no one no one's
ever spot loss treatment really scary
especially when you got oh here we go
he's gonna be swapping on over to the
scare I'll pick
do you play the girls earlier put in so
much work with it well see we can double
down and change the scenario of this
match heading into game two linkers vs.
Louis yeah girl what was what put in so
much work force chen chen basically i
almost effectively shutting the Shan
Chen's entire game plan out all right
now the weird thing is is like I put a
lot of stock and he was like he to be
fine honest with you in some free losing
that can be you know trying to run back
to that game plan that you feel any
talks about being a very defensive
players and just tried to get easier
rhythm and I don't you out or whatever
you trying to do
yeah you work something out here but
sure
step party he does not want to deal with
it but okay step card right there those
aromas cape on the back they're very
very close to mine either in kadai and
maybe two hits or just one real Queen
goodness
Oh what they were the stem pitch nine
second foot on the clock will know is
gonna be the initiator of Seoul tries to
stop the clock he is very very close to
dying right there he's got the hit now
he is the one we need but there it is
off the whip punished we try to set
never be crippled that age if not
otherwise eat this fire baby just like
that we don't logo bring it back giving
it to the people didn't quit a large
likely here or yet the physique without
marker they're a little sudden the trend
for a lot of damage the very beginning
but the thing is boy bet you get that
burn you can set up for a lot more
afterwards we act some respect right
each other's face does it take a little
bit of meters for his trouble
Oh Mike that could have been real bad if
I didn't class got the hit though and
caught on Wow
so strong during this battle manly boys
trying to rock it out of the wall right
and be beat it
all right I feel like this is one of the
first few times that I've seen someone
go to as many of the healthiest possible
babes like yo cbut so you can actually
do in a row right there yeah he didn't
want to have to deal with that situation
you know we court didn't end up going
through grab but I mean look at the feet
are going in there do blockable that's
gonna finish it off and now low low
points right now looking to put me
towards possibly in a loser's bracket
right now we're having a ton of trouble
being able to move for it okay look put
the crab right there okay I'll sure
pressure watch your ankles oh baby let's
go
yeah like that he didn't cancel in a
bird you recognize it it with
get quick damage here though I can't now
he's starting to go to the whis punished
game rights walk with punish block
punish or etc he's not trying to take
you when you say a champion especially
given then he was at the land of death
here we go
oh man the follow-up damage not have to
kill though yeah look we eat your
depression from far away right yeah and
of course Lola wants to go for the ring
out so he's of course gonna spend that
bar
no dice however as the link words gonna
tie it up through tutu and round tied up
a meeting right now so let's see if
looking clothes and out and finishes
plate otherwise they're gonna go to
another match old cups pre-k just
connect this time to be a little bit
follow-up damage but big killer didn't
mrs. get the biggest punish but I mean
hey you get up after we expect the I but
there's the sole charge doesn't want to
deal with the plus frames get off me I
need to put often mad Jim and they
taking it to Oh over link or I'm not
sure which spell link attempted to do as
he ran up maybe yours maybe burn or
whatever the case may be
Lolo hits him out of it before he got it
and that was gonna finish it off
he puts link [ __ ] into the losers and
he know where that puts him
put them with was that was that that was
when we 73 yes very